[Music]
when I first learned about Iran like
most people I was exposed exclusively to
stuff like this but as I started to look
closer I started to see a much different
Iran than what the Islamic Republic
regime represents the reaction in Iran
to the news about a potential deal is a
good example of what I'm talking about
immediately following the news of this
deal with the West people lined up to
greet foreign minister Zarif as he
returned from Switzerland they spent all
night celebrating the potential lifting
of sanctions and closer ties with the
West so what's going on here is Iran
this or is it this a while back I
reached out to 25 Iran Ian's on Facebook
these were people between the ages of 21
and 35 who lived all over the country I
started following them and realizing
that they were totally normal people
they posted cat videos and took pictures
of their food and talked about clothes
and sports and plenty of selfies I never
once saw a dogmatically religious post
and I certainly never saw anything anti
Western
[Music]
I started to realize that there was a
big difference between what I had
studied about this regime and what the
people were actually like these were
people who were born after the 1979
revolution they were not a part of the
emotion and the zeal that brought about
the current Iran and all of its
hostilities towards the west instead
they grew up in an environment of
increasing seclusion from the world on
one hand while gaining huge access to
the world through the internet on the
other hand
so in today's Iran people are less
likely to hate Americans in my effort to
befriend Iranians on Facebook I didn't
have a single person reject my friend
requests in fact most of them sent me a
message telling me how happy they were
to connect and how they would love to
talk more about our different cultures
politics wasn't a big part of this
conversation so no matter how easy it is
to label Iran is this pariah nation bent
on hardline religious fundamentalism
remember that while there are definitely
supporters of that ideology there's a
whole other side to this country that we
rarely see most Iranian czar normal
people living normal lives they want to
connect they want to feel safe and they
want peace as much as you and I do
that's something I think we could afford
to talk about a little bit more
[Music]